فتحت
الجلسه المحكمه تجتمع من اجل اصدار حكمها
فيما يتعلق بفرض تدابير مؤقته طلبتها جنوب
افريقيا في القضيه المتعلقه بتطبيق
وقفي
ومعاقبه الجرائم المرتبطه بالعباده
الجماعيه في القضيه المقدمه منب افريد
اسرائيل القاضي روبنسون والذي شارك بشكل
مشترك في كل من المداولات والقرار النهائي
والاسباب معروفه لي لم يكن قادرا على
المتواجد معنا في
مقعده اليوم اود ان ارحب
بالممثل الموقر لجنوب افريقيا ول دوله
اسرائيل في وبشكل خاص اود ايضا ان اشكر
وجود سعادتي ناليدي بندور وزيره العلاقات
الدوليه والتعاون في جنوب افريقيا واتذكر
بانه في ال9 من ديسمبر 2023 جنوب افريقيا
قد قدمت طلبا في سجن للمحكمه
لتطبيق اجراءات بمزاعم انتهاكات في غزه
والالتزامات بموجب اتفاقيه الاباده
الجماعيه
و المشار لها بالقضيه ان طلب جنوب افريقيا
طلب بفرض تدابير
مؤقته وبما يتعلق
بال الميثاق والبن 41 و57 و54 وفيما ووفق
الممارسات المتعارف عليها والفقره
التعريفيه والتي حددت الاجراءات وبالتالي
اود ان نوجز بعض الفق فرات ايضا واحذف
بعضها وسوف نبدا الان
بقراءه الفقره الثال
ع وفي الامر
المحكمه وضعت السياق الكامل للقضيه
المقدمه امامها ولاحظت بانه في السابع من
اكتوبر 2023 حماس وغيرها من المجموعات
المسلحه المتواجده في قطاع غزه قامت بشن
هجوم على اسرائيل قتلت فيه اكثر من 1200
شخص وجرحت الالاف واختطفت قرابه 240 شخصا
عديدين منهم لا يزالون في الاسر وعقب هذا
الهجوم اسرائيل قامت بشن عمليه عسكريه
واسعه النطاق في غزه برا وبحرا وجوا والذي
تسبب بادرا خسائر بشريه كبيره ودمار كبير
للبنى التحتيه
ونزوح لاغلب العظمى
للشعب الغزي المحكمه مدركه تماما الى اي
مدا الماسا الانسانيه تتكشف في المنطقه
وهي قلقه جدا من استمرار فقدان الارواح
والمعاناه
الانسانيه ان الصراع المستمر في غزه تم
التعاطي معه مع عديد من وكاله الامم
المتحده وبشكل خاص هنالك كانت تحفظات تم
تبنتها الجمعيه العامه ومجلس الامن واشير
الى كثير من جوانب هذا الصراع فان نطاق
القضيه مطروحه امام القضيه هو محدود وجنوب
افريقيا قد بدات في هذه الاجراءات بموجب
اتفاقيه الاباده الجماعيه وعندها تحولت
المحكمه الى اشتراط اللازمه من والوفاء
بها من اجل النظر في التدابير المؤقته
وفيما تعلق بالسؤال الوجاهه القضائيه فال
المحكمه خلصت بانه من اجل فرض هذه
التدابير فقط هذه التدابير
عندما تتحقق هذه الاختصاص ومن اسس تثبتها
المحكمه
و وان المحكمه لها اختصاص فيما يتعلق
بجوهر هذه الدعوه في القضيه
الحاليه المقدمه من جنوب افريقيا وفقا
للفقره 63 البند الاول من ميثاق المحكمه
والماده تسعه من اتفاقيه بد جماعيه
المحكمه قد حددت فيما
ان هنالك اشتراطات وت الوفاء بها فيما
يتعلق ببتي او نظري في جوهره
الدعوه وايضا من اجل الامكانيه في فرض
التدبير او الب النظري في التدابير
المؤقته الماده التاسعه من الاتفاقيه
واقتبس منها بان النزاع بين الاطراف
المتعاقده فيما يتعلق بتفسير وتطبيقي او
اشتراطات الاتفاقيه بما في بما في ذلك
مسؤوليه الدول عن اباده جماعيه او غيرها
من الاعمال المنصوص عليها في الفقره 13
يمكن رفعها الى محكمه العدل الدوليه وبناء
على طلب
الاطراف الموقعين على هذه الاتفاقيه نهايه
الاقتص جنوب افريقيا واسرائيل هما موقعت
او اطرافي
الاتفاقيه ولا احد منهم عنده اي تحفظ على
الماده التاسعه او غيرها من بنود الماده
وعندها ايضا تستدعي المحكمه بانه بموجب
اتفاقيه الاباده
الجماعيه يجعل الاختصاص مشروطا في النزاع
ودون نظر في راته ان
النزاع
المتعلق بالوجهات القانونيه المختلفه من
كلا الاطراف ومن اجل وجود نزاع ينبغي ان
يظهر بان زعم احد الاطراف
هو مدرك او تم الاعلام للطرف الاخر كان
هنالك العديد من وجهات النظر فيما
يتعلق بالواجبات الدوليه ومن اجل تحديد
فيما اذا كان هنالك نزاع في القضيه
الحاليه لا يمكن ان تقتصر محكمه دورها على
اذا كان طرف يرى بان الاتفاقيه تطبق او لا
تطبق وبما ان جنوب افريقيا قد طلبت
من
المحكمه النظر في القضيه واباده جماعيه
والانتهاك هذه الاتفاقيه
فالمحكمة ا اتخاذ قرار فيما اذا كان
هنالك نزاع بين الطرفين في وقت تقديم
الطلب تم الاخذ بعين الاعتبار بشكل خاص
ايه بيانات او وثائق تم تبادلها بين
الاطراف وايضا فيما اذا كان لك ايه
تبادلات في بيئات متعدده الاطراف وايضا
المحكمه انتبهت الى ه لفتت نظرها الى هذه
الوثائق والتصريحات و والمساله كانت تتعلق
بحكم
محكمتي ومن
منطلق الموضوعيه وان
بيان جنوب افريقيا وتصريحاتها في عدد من
المنتديات العامه والثنائيه والمتعلق
بطبيعه ونطاق العمليات العسكريه
الاسرائيليه في غزه وان اجراءات اسرائيل
وصلت الى ما يمثل انتهاكا لمات اسرائيل
باتفاقيه باده الجماعيه فعلى سبيل المثال
في الجلسه العاشره الاستثنائيه ل الجمعيه
العامه للامم المتحده في الثان عش من
ديسمبر
2023 والتي تم تمثيل اسرائيل
فيها جنوب افريقيا في تصريحها قالت بانه
في احداث السته اسابيع الماضيه في
غزه اسرائيل تصرفت بما يتناقض مع
التزاماتها بموجب اتفاقيه الاباده
الجماعيه نهايه الاقتباس جنوب
افريقيا اشارت الى هذا البيان في وارسلت
ايضا رساله الى السفاره الاسرائيليه في
بريتوريا في 21 من ديسمبر ايضا وبرفض
اسرائيل
لكل اتهامات ووزاره الخارجيه الاسرائيليه
في السادس من ديسمبر 2023 اصدرت بيانا
تنفي في هذه المزاع وحتى على الموقع
الالكتروني لوزاره الدفاعي في من ديسمبر
وتحت عنوان بان الحرب ضد
حماس واشارت واقتبس عنهم بان الاتهامات
جمعيه ضد اسرائيل هي لا اساس لها و وهي
مرفوضه اخلاقيا نهايه الاقتباس وفي
الوثيقه اسرائيل ايضا اشارت واقتبسوا بان
الاتهامات ارتكاب اباده جماعيه هي ليست
فقط غير قانونيه ولكنها سخيفه وانه لا
توجد هنالك اسس
صحيحه حول هذه التهم الغير مقبول بارتكاب
الجماعيه نهايه الاقتباس وفي ضوء ما سبق
المحكمه
نظرت وبحثت في ان الاطراف لديهم وجهات
نظر مختلفه حول اجراءات اسرائيل في غزه
والتي من الطرف انها تصل الى ما يشكل
انتهاكا لاتفاقيه ابده ال جماعيه و ورايه
الطرف المدعي بان هنالك ما يكفي من الادله
لاثبات هذا
و وخاصه فيما يتعلق
بتفسير الاتفاق ب اتفاقيه الباده الجماعيه
وفيما اذا كانت الاجراءات والشكوى التي
قدمها الطرف
المدعي